that'll really really
shown him up wouldn't it
brought in some burritos or some
colored greens or some
Pad Thai love Pad Thai it's collard
greens okay well it's after five so
thank you very much
Buena Vista Oscar
thank you good job I'm a man
thank you Brazil
nice
oh
we can go
uh
uh not a bad day
what
do you want to tell me something you
look like you want to tell me something
you look like you have something really
important to say and you just can't for
some reason
come on you can tell me
Jim
tell me anything
oh wow that is really interesting what
your love I'm just kidding I can't see
it man look closer
oh okay good point for me tied up oh
you're dead what are you gonna do bring
it easily bring it oh yeah the move oh
not such an ultimate fighter now huh hey
put me down
oh my God hey put me down hey
hey okay gentlemen listen up
so this year for the first time ever I
got Pam in secret Santa and I got to
this uh teapot which I know she really
wants so she can make tea at her desk
but I'm also gonna stuff it with some
inside jokes
like
this is my high school yearbook photo
she sat at the party and it really makes
her laugh
not sure why
um what else oh
this is a hot sauce packet she put this
on a hot dog a couple years ago because
she thought it was ketchup
and uh it was really funny so I kept the
other two this would take a little too
long to explain so I won't and this is
the card
because Christmas is the time to tell
people how you feel
you know you don't have to answer calls
during a party just thought you should
know no I was just um checking out my
present
I traded with Dwight
um just I figured you know you went to a
lot of trouble and it means a lot
and also Roy got me an iPad or uh was
going to get me an iPad so
well either way
this is an amazing gift because it comes
with bonus gifts
look inside
foreign
yeah I think I made the right choice
oh my God this is incredible is this the
Boggle timer I didn't think you were
gonna get that one I really did
what
oh nothing
Pam's on vacation and she gets back
tomorrow so it'll be nice to see her
it'll be nice and uh she set a date for
the wedding with Roy uh June summer so
that'll be nice
and that's that
what
oh nothing
um
I'm sorry for pushing you toward
Cumberland
seriously if you left here I would blow
my brains out
that's just a figure of speech you know
blow your brains out come on all it
really means is that we're friends and
who else should you come to talk to if
I'm gone right
I mean if she left I wouldn't blow my
brains out
of course I would take that job in
Maryland because it's double the pay and
soft shell crab just happens to be my
favorite food
um
I'm sorry for pushing you toward
Cumberland
seriously if you left here I would blow
my brains out
that's just a figure of speech you know
blow your brains out come on all it
really means is that we're friends and
who else is she going to talk to if I'm
gone right
I mean if she left I wouldn't blow my
brains out
of course I would take that job in
Maryland because it's double the pay and
soft shell crab just happens to be my
favorite food
[Music]
getting kind of Rowdy down there yeah
sometimes I just don't get Roy
I mean I don't know
so
what's it like dating a cheerleader
oh
um
I'm cold
your office buildings on fire Jim who
would you say
the customer
customers came
you know what I would save the
receptionist I just wanted to clear that
out
[Music]
hey everybody you know can I get your
attention for uh just a second you
listen to me for a second um we were up
at the front and we were talking about
that's really important and
Pam
um
I think enough is enough I think we
should set a day for our wedding uh June
10th come on let's do it
[Applause]
thank you
yeah right yeah right what what was this
[Laughter]
I have good cards really and I'm going
to take you all in WoW
I think you're bluffing
foreign
yeah I think she's full of it
straight
three nine
Jim Albert ladies
thank you very much it was fun
uh oh hey do you have your quarterly
numbers yes absolutely the questionnaire
sorry to make you fill that thing out oh
no absolutely HR formality we have this
very irritating HR guy here he's
probably the only person you're not
gonna like I bet Jim got the job
I mean why wouldn't he he's totally
qualified and smart everyone loves him
and if he never comes back again
that's okay
we're friends and I'm sure we'll stay
friends
we just we never got the timing right
you know I shot him down and then he did
the same to me and
but you know what it's okay
I'm totally fine
everything is going to be totally sorry
um are you free for dinner tonight
yes
all right
then it's a date
I'm sorry what was the question
foreign